welcome to this session
on how google cloud's delivering
enterprise transformation at scale
my name is mahmoud elliser and i lead
customer experience for our strategic
accounts
at google cloud i joined google in late
2019
after spending over two decades at
verizon where i had multiple technology
leadership roles
like the senior vice president and cio
for our files business
and in the past four and a half years i
was the senior vice president
and cto for it where i led the verizon
journey to the cloud with aws
oracle gcp and started the
transformation of verizon
into a data-driven powerhouse it's
interesting to note
how technology changes so fast
in 2016 aws was the right choice for
data center migration just like the main
frameworks that i chose in the 70s and
80s
today it's all about multi-cloud it's
all about applied ai
so i cannot be more excited to be here
at google building our
enterprise experience and and
teams and helping our most strategic
customers
unlock the superior capabilities of
google cloud and helping them to
transform and win faster
our mission and customer experience is
to help our customer
adopt and realize value from google
cloud solutions
we win when our customers win i hope you
had a chance to watch john jester
and melanie bragg's session which goes
into a deep
into how we're investing and building
our customer experience organization
today i have two objectives
one first i would like to highlight how
we're orienting our customer experience
to
to support our most strategic customers
then i want to share a few examples on
the
work we are doing to support our
strategic customers
across different industries
we are building deep expertise for
enterprise
in every region and every industry
to help our customers transform and win
globally and this list is growing
rapidly
with many new kind of partnerships that
we are announcing during next on air
over the nine weeks period
by listening deeply to our customers
you and we have built our
strategy under thomas's leadership
and we are creating a customer
experience organization
with more depth credibility and
enterprise readiness
within customer experience we have five
main pillars
our professional services teams now can
help you with
data center migration with mainframe
migration
and with scaling ai and ml solutions
we restructured our support team to have
more customer context
and to have deeper expertise in the
products and services
of google cloud also earlier this year
we launched a premium support offering
with a mission critical support option
that will give you five minutes
p0 slo our learning team
recently launched skills and
knowledge badges and certification
program
to help you build deep expertise into
our modern technologies our customer
success team is continuously
is engaging with you to help you
accelerate the time to onboard on our
cloud
and to build your customer success plan
helping you realize value
faster from our solutions
and we continuously build our and
improve our products and services by
listening to you our customers
also the feedback we get from our
partners so that's a huge investment
we're also making
this year and lastly so we're building
my team which is the i would say the
transformation officers team
so this is a team of industry cios and
ctos
that we're hiring to cover our strategic
customers in every industry
and they bring two items to the table
first they bl
they bring deep industry knowledge in
their respective industries we're
focusing on
and two they bring credibility of having
led at
technology transformation at scale
in that in that industry let's go a
little bit deeper into these
transformation officer roles there are
three key ways they help you
transform first of all they provide
strategic thought leadership for you and
your team
through this transformation journey and
adopting cloud
and the way kind of the the
transformation officers focus
on handful of clients like two to three
customers at a time
and this will allow them to spend lots
of time and collaborate with you and
your team
to help you be the transform
in your business and win in your markets
at the same time
these transformation officers will act
as the coaches for our
google side and continuously work with
our team to continuously de-risk
the program and help them kind of think
as
be in the shoes of the customer and
build customer empathy
and continuously de-risking to ensure
delivery
and the third area these transformation
officers work across google
and google cloud with other partners
like google health and
verily and google travel and google
automotive services and android and
everywhere in google to help pull these
expertise to help you differentiate in
your transformation
and deliver faster
so as you can see you get lots of lots
of support
when you work with us here's an example
of the google
cloud customer team as you can see
there are many individuals on this page
all of whom
are here to support you through this
journey
of partnering with us and migrating to
the cloud
the transformation officer play key role
in engaging with you and your leadership
team as well as providing guidance
to our account team this is a service
that we provide
throughout the delivery and it is
something that we believe differentiate
google cloud
here are a few examples i want to start
with the healthcare industry
so we just hired ryan terry who is the
business president
at hillerom which is a medical kind of
platform device platform
and he's done lots of transformation in
in the healthcare industry
so how the healthcare industry has been
at the forefront of the fight against
koved
working tirelessly to accelerate drug
development
meet heightened demand for ppe and
rethink the delivery of patient care
there are three areas we're focusing on
with our healthcare
customers first one is telehealth
the global pandemic has proven that
telehealth is an effective way
to deliver care according to mckinsey
research
consumer adoption of telehealth has
skyrocketed from 11
to 46 percent and 74 percent
of telehealth users have reported
satisfaction our team is working with
several providers to build clinical and
patient
friendly telehealth platforms with ease
integration to hospital scheduling and
ehr systems
the other area is advanced clinical
research
with faster times to drug approval and
better patient outcomes
is a priority we are using our
unparalleled tools
in high performance computing and aiml
to develop sophisticated models to
expedite the drug
discovery and approval process and
finally we're working with
hospitals to enable better decision
making
for caregiver and within business
function
throughout the use of analytical tools
with more streamlined ways
to access data from disparate systems
shifting gears to the the financial
services industry
and this is where we hired like david
knott as he was the chief
architect at hsbc so our financial
services customers are on exciting and
journey and challenging journey also to
redefine the banking
experience they all want to transform
the experience for their customers they
want to reduce risk and they want to
do increase collaboration among their
teams
we're currently partnering with our
financial services
customers to mainly do a few things one
they want to migrate off the mainframe
and build cloud-native
platforms for banking which allow them
to innovate and
and more faster for their customers and
change the experience
and be much more nimble than agile the
other area is they want to reimagine the
customer experience with the use of data
and machine learning and they're
building 360 view of the customer
which is helping them build more
customized and tailored offers
and services for their customers and
lastly
we are also co-creating new products
with
uh with our with our financial services
customers especially folk
when it comes to fraud and anti-money
laundering and so forth and so on and
this is where we're matching their
kind of expertise with our aiml superior
capabilities and talent to transform and
create
these products another industry here i
have is telecom and that's dear to my
heart and we hired we have two
transformation officers in the space to
cover
our customers globally one is kevin
schatzkammer so kevin
recently joined us from dell he was the
cto for the service provider
industry and the other one is frederick
vanutzhe and he was the ctio at
megaphone
uh so kevin is on board frederick will
be joining us next month
and we're so excited to have them our
telecom customers want to monetize
their 5g investments and transform into
data-driven powerhouses
to drive both capital and expense
efficiencies they're also looking for
new ways to innovate and provide
better experience for their customers so
we're working with them in like three
key areas
the first one is transforming their
customer experience so
we're launching we launched this product
called calls contact center ai
which is allowing our our telecom
customers to do two things transform
their customer experience and their cost
structure at the same time
contact center ai allows our customers
to auto create
both chat bots and voice bots with our
superior kind of text-to-speech and
special text capability which is
nlp capabilities and we have amazing
results in the space and and this
product applies not just a telecom it
applies to any industry
or customer that have uh that are heavy
on
call centers the second area we're
expanding our
mobile edge footprint and partnering
with multiple telcos
in this space to transform both the
consumer and create new enterprise
experiences that will harness the power
of low latency and
high throughput finally we are using
applied analytics and aiml capabilities
to help our customers
uh drive efficiency in their capital and
expand spend
through like a tool we have a new tool i
encourage everybody to come and talk to
us about it called
network planner shifting gears into
travel and transportation so we hired
ravi
simhambatla from he was the cto at
united airlines ravi has been on board
for the past since
earlier this year and he's been heavily
engaged with our strategic customers and
the travel business
and there are fewer industries that have
been more impacted by kovid
than the travel industry and rather than
scaling back
uh their investments we have seen our
customers use this opportunity to
accelerate their digital transformation
and we are very proud to be supporting
them during
these times some of the key areas we're
working
with our customers across this industry
are i would say one is getting them out
of their data centers
and getting them off the mainframe into
our cloud platform
and helping them change the culture to
be much more agile
build devops and build sre for
operations
the other area is they're using our
superior ai
ml capabilities and talent to drive
efficiencies
in their operations and especially their
irregular operations
basically when the weather there's a
storm and they need to reschedule
everything
so how do you use aiml for that how do
you plan the last
last mile routing so lots of
opportunities here
to reinvent that business with our
superior capabilities
and finally we're also partnering with
them and like this is an area where we
pull google travel into this
and to help create new products and
services for both consumer
and enterprise customers and allow them
to make new kind of
types of revenue so these are a few
examples i share with you
of of the work we're doing across
supporting to support our customers
transform and
differentiate and innovate across
multiple industries there are many more
examples i'm happy
uh to talk about them more in a
different occasion
in closing i'd like to leave you with uh
three key takeaways the first one i hope
you see the customer centricity we at
google cloud
are all about you our customers and
helping you realize
value through our products and solutions
the second one we continue to make big
investments
to support you our enterprise customers
the transformation officers are part of
that
of that investment but as you can heard
from
thomas and and john we're tripling the
investment
in our go to market teams and that's
where we're investing in our
transformation officers team
and the third area you can see google
cloud also we can pull in all the assets
across these transformation officers
will pull in
all the assets from across google to
help you differentiate your experiences
for your customers
and help you win faster
i hope you enjoyed our discussion today
here are a few final tips to go deeper
and please do not hesitate to reach out
to your sales rep
if you'd like to set up a conversation
with me or
anybody from my team we're happy to go
deeper with you
and answer any kind of questions or
tackle
any kind of opportunities you have
we look forward to hearing from you and
thank you for
tuning in
you